die puppe muss schlafen die zweijährige
anna aber ist noch putzmunter
auch wenn es gleich abendbrot gibt bei
den bayerisches die familie hat
insgesamt fünf kinder vater johannes
arbeitet als jurist bei einer bank er
kommt immer erst gegen 18 uhr nach hause
mutter veronika ist freiberufliche
musiklehrerin als solche kann sie
familie und beruf gut miteinander
verbinden
wenn ein kind kam dann habe ich immer
unterbrochen und dann habe ich wieder
sehr wenige angefangen und jetzt langsam
habe ich wieder mache ich immer mehr so
dass es immer gut geht also ich staffel
das letztendlich immer so dass es immer
ganz gut hier reinpasst dass die kinder
nicht zu kurz kommen und ich auch nicht
die bei matches leben in berlin eine
familie noch dazu so eine große sei
nicht unbedingt karriere förderlich
meint der vater aber die familie
entschädigen dafür sei nicht immer gut
gelaufen so dass wir relativ bald nach
der geburt eines kindes zu kommen sind
das musste das letzte gewesen sein viel
typischer für deutschlands familien aber
sind stefan enten und aline krämer
stefan ist gründer eines internet
startups aline selbstständige
unternehmensberaterin
beide sind über 30 letzte woche sind sie
in eine neue wohnung gezogen
in der soll es irgendwann auch mal
kinder geben ein ziel was erreicht sein
muss
persönliche sache wann das für sich für
uns richtig anfühlt glaube ich
vielleicht noch mal vorher noch mal eine
weltreise sowie die beiden denken viele
deutsche vor allem die gut ausgebildeten
wollen immer später kinder und genau das
ist das problem warnen wissenschaftler
denn die fruchtbarkeit der frau lasse ab
deutlich nach paare warten oftmals auch
zu lange weil sie glauben das wird schon
gehen und wir nicht machen wir eben
reproduktionsmedizin und die kinder die
zwischen 20 und 30 nicht geboren werden
werden nur zum teil nach dem dreißigsten
lebensjahr geboren das heißt das ist zum
teil sind das verlorene möglichkeiten im
internationalen vergleich liegt
deutschland bei der geburtenrate weit
hinten mit durchschnittlich nur 1 4
kindern pro frau
spitzenreiter unter den großen
industrienationen ist frankreich mit
über zwei kindern geburten starke länder
wie frankreich oder schweden geben im
verhältnis deutlich mehr geld für
familienpolitik aus als deutschland
das bekommen auch die bayerische zu
spüren anzahl und qualität von
betreuungseinrichtungen sind im ausland
oft besser deutschland investiert zwei
drittel der familienförderung in
geldleistungen für das kindergeld allein
rund 40 milliarden euro jährlich
geld das sinnvoller ausgegeben werden
könnte finden die bei matches
wir wussten nicht von irgendeiner
staatliche förderung für familien
davos geplant haben nachwuchs bekommen
haben noch was in irgendeiner weise für
zweiten und trotzdem plant die
bundesregierung bereits die nächste
finanzielle wohltaten betreuungsgeld
dass eltern erhalten sollen ihre kinder
nicht in eine kindertagesstätte schicken
das nützt auch nichts alle drei jahre
die politik neu zu definieren was paare
mit kinderwunsch brauchen ist eine
langfristige perspektive und
verlässlichkeit des hand hat sich länder
wie frankreich und skandinavien sehr gut
geschafft
die aussicht auf 180 euro kindergeld
spiele bei ihrer entscheidung für ein
kind keine rolle
ein mögliches betreuungsgeld erst recht
nicht so das junge paar
viel wichtiger seien
betreuungsmöglichkeiten von denen gebe
es immer noch viel zu wenige auch die
bayerische sagen ohne zusätzliche hilfe
durch die großeltern die ebenfalls in
berlin leben würden sie die betreuung
ihrer kinder gar nicht schaffen
über all das aber hätten sie sich vor
der geburt ihrer kinder gar nicht so
viele gedanken gemacht
es war auch eine bauchentscheidung die
man so schön sagt einfach und ich glaube
dass das ja dass es auch wichtig ist
dass es eine bauchentscheidung auch
einigermaßen ist sonst spricht ja auch
kann einfach zu viel auf dagegen
sprechen vielleicht die bei matches
haben ihr familienglück gefunden
deutschlands familienpolitik zum trotz